Se couvrir et mettre de l'anti-moustique fonctionne,
jusqu'à ce que vous oubliiez.
(Rires)
Cela nous laisse les moustiques, et voici comment nous les contrôlons :
en pulvérisant des insecticides.
La tenue de protection est nécessaire car ce sont des produits toxiques
qui tuent les gens aussi bien que les insectes.
Bien qu'il en faille beaucoup plus pour tuer une personne qu'un insecte.
Ce sont des photos du Brésil et du Nicaragua.
Mais c'est pareil à Miami, en Floride.
Et nous pouvons bien-sûr répandre de l'insecticide des avions.
L'été dernier, des responsables du contrôle de moustiques
dans le conté de Dorchester, en Caroline du Sud,
ont autorisé la diffusion du Naled, un insecticide,
tôt un matin, comme recommandé par les fabricants.
Plus tard ce jour-là, une apicultrice a déclaré à des reporters
que ses ruches avaient l'air d'avoir été atomisées.
Oups.
Les abeilles sont « les gentils ».
Les citoyens de Floride ont protesté, mais la pulvérisation a continué.
Malheureusement, tout comme le nombre de cas de fièvre Zika.
Parce que les insecticides ne sont pas très efficaces.
Existe-t-il donc des approches peut-être plus efficaces que la pulvérisation
mais avec moins d'inconvénients que les produit toxiques ?
Je suis une grande fan des contrôles biologiques,
je partage cette idée avec Rachel Carson, auteure de « Printemps silencieux »
le livre reconnu pour avoir lancé le mouvement écologiste.
Dans ce livre, elle raconte, comme exemple,
comment un très mauvais insecte, nuisible pour l'élevage
a été éradiqué au siècle dernier.
Personne ne connaît cette histoire incroyable aujourd'hui.
Donc Jack Block et moi, lorsque nous écrivions notre édito
sur les problème actuels liés aux moustiques,
nous avons raconté cette histoire.
En quelques mots, les nymphes, la larve de l'insecte
ont été éradiquées jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient stériles,
cultivées jusqu'à l'âge adulte,
puis relâchées par avion dans tout le Sud-Ouest,
le Sud-Est et jusqu'au Mexique et à l'Amérique Centrale
littéralement par millions depuis des petits avions,
éliminant finalement ce terrible nuisible
de la majeur partie de l'hémisphère ouest.
Notre véritable but en écrivant cet édito
était de montrer aux lecteurs comment on peut s'y prendre aujourd'hui,
pas avec la radiation, mais avec nos connaissances en génétique.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer.
Voici le coupable : Aedes aegypti
L'insect vecteur de maladies le plus commun,
pas seulement Zika mais aussi la dengue, Chikungunya, le virus du Nil occidental
et de cet ancien fléau, la fièvre jaune.
C'est un moustique urbain,
et c'est la femelle qui fait le sale boulot.
Elle pique pour nourrir sa progéniture.
Les mâles ne piquent pas, ils n'ont même pas la trompe pour piquer.
Une petite entreprise britannique, Oxitec, a modifié génétiquement ce moustique
afin que lorsque qu'il se reproduise avec une femelle sauvage,
ses oeufs ne se développent pas jusqu'à l'âge adulte.
Je vais vous montrer.
Voici le cycle reproductif normal.
Oxitec a modifié le moustique afin que lorsque le mâle
se reproduit avec la femelle sauvage
ses oeufs ne se développent pas.
Ça a l'air impossible ?
Je vais vous montrer avec un schéma comment ils ont fait.
Cela représente le noyau d'une cellule de moustique,
et cet amas au milieu représente son génome,
la totalité de ses gènes.
Les scientifiques ont ajouté un gène isolé
qui code une protéine représentée par cette balle orange
qui se nourrit elle-même, créant plus de protéines.
Les copies supplémentaire s'attachent aux gènes du moustique
tuant l'organisme.
Pour le maintenir en vie en laboratoire, ils utilisent de la tétracycline.
La tétracycline « éteint » ce gène et permet un développement normal.
Ils ont ajouté une autre trouvaille pour pouvoir étudier ce qu'il arrive.
Ils ont ajouté un gène qui rend l'insecte luisant sous les UV
afin de voir à quel distance il va lorsqu'il est relâché,
combien de temps il vit et tout ce genre de données utiles
pour obtenir une étude scientifique de qualité.
Voici le stade nymphal, à ce stade
les femelles sont plus grandes que les mâles.
Cela leur permet de trier mâles et femelles
et ils ne laissent que les mâles se développer.
Et je vous rappelle que les mâles ne piquent pas.
De là, c'est assez simple.
Ils prennent des béchers pleins de moustiques mâles,
les mettent dans des briques de lait, et conduisent dans la ville,
les relâchant en étant guidés par GPS.
Voici le maire d'une ville relâchant le premier groupe
de ce qu'ils appellent le « Aedes ami ».
J'aimerais pouvoir vous dire qu'il s'agit d'une ville américaine, mais non.
C'est Piracicaba, au Brésil.
Ce qui est étonnant est qu'en seulement un an,
cela a fait baissé les cas de dengue de 91 %.
C'est mieux que n'importe quel anti-moustique.
Alors pourquoi n'utilisons-nous pas
ce remarquable contrôle biologique aux USA ?
C'est parce que c'est un OGM : un organisme génétiquement modifié.
Vous noterez que le sous-titre ici dit que si la FDA les y autorisait,
ils pourraient faire la même chose ici, quand Zika apparaîtrait.
Et bien sûr il est apparu.
Maintenant, je dois vous raconter la version courte
de la longue, tortueuse histoire de la régulation des OGM aux USA.
Aux USA, il y a trois agences qui régulent les organismes génétiquement modifiés :
la FDA, Agence américaine des produits alimentaires et médicamenteux,
l'EPA, Agence américaine de protection de l'environnement,
et l'USDA, le Département de l'agriculture des Etats-Unis.
Cela leur a pris deux ans à décider que cela serait la FDA
qui réglementera le moustique génétiquement modifié.
Et elle le ferait comme si c'était un nouveau médicament vétérinaire,
selon leur logique.
Cela leur a pris cinq ans de plus d'allers-retours
pour convaincre la FDA que cela ne nuirait pas aux gens,
que cela ne nuirait pas à l'environnement.
Ils leur ont finalement donné, cet été, la permission de faire un petit test
dans les îles Keys de Floride,
où ils avaient été invités des années auparavant
quand les îles avaient connu une épidémie de dengue.
Cela aurait pu être simple.
Quand les habitants ont appris
qu'il y aurait des tests de moustiques génétiquement modifiés
dans leur communauté,
certains ont organisé des manifestations.
Ils ont même organisé une pétition sur internet avec ce charmant logo,
qui a obtenu 160 000 signatures.
Et ils ont exigé un référendum
qui sera mené dans quelques semaines
sur l'autorisation pure et simple des tests.
C'est Miami qui a besoin de ces meilleures techniques pour contrôler les insectes.
Et là-bas, les attitudes changent.
Très récemment, un groupe bipartisan de plus de 60 législateurs
a écrit à la Secrétaire du Département de la santé, Sylvia Burwell,
en lui demandant d'accélérer au niveau fédéral l'accès de la Floride
à cette nouvelle technologie.
En conclusion :
un contrôle biologique d'insectes dangereux
peut être à la fois plus efficace et bien plus respectueux de l'environnement
que d'utiliser des insecticides, qui sont des produits toxiques.
C'était vrai au temps de Rachel Carson, ça l'est encore aujourd'hui.
La différence, c'est que nous avons énormément plus d'information
sur la génétique que nous en avions à cette époque,
et donc plus de capacité à utiliser ces informations
pour influencer ces contrôles biologiques.
J'espère avoir chatouillé votre curiosité
pour que vous commenciez votre propre recherche,
pas seulement sur les moustiques génétiquement modifiés
mais sur les autres OGM si controversés aujourd'hui.
Je pense que si vous le faites, et que vous creusez, à travers la désinformation
et le marketing
de la part de l'industrie alimentaire biologique et de Greenpeace
et trouvez la science, la science exacte,
vous serez surpris et ravis.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)